welcome back to Facebook nonsense I
don't want to introduce you to Bella
Bella's a three-year-old dog who was
rescued by her owner Jonathan Miller I
bumped it to Jonathan at Royal Ascot on
Friday and he mentioned that Bella's
likely to have become the only dog in
history to have been canceled and it's
because of pride month well I said too
Jonathan you better come on to Piers
Morgan downstairs and explain him his
extraordinary story with Jonathan and
Bella welcome to Piers Morgan and
sentencing what happened
well it's uh I was in London last week
as you know we did have the pleasure of
seeing each other and I was uh we have a
little flat in London I live in France
and I was struck by the ubiquitous uh
branding for Pride everywhere I went to
Tesco it was
blessing with with pride Flags Regent
Street pride the pub next door Pride
everything was pride and it I began I'm
sorry I'm a bit of a grumpy old guy I
guess but it's struck me as being
Slightly bizarre why is there such a
thing as pride month we give one day a
year to Veterans who died defending
their country A Day to mothers A Day to
fathers maybe a couple of days to Jesus
but a month for Pride anyway at this
moment I received an email from a
company called attractive in Austria
which makes a GPS tracker which lets me
keep an eye on Bella as she hunts in the
uh in the vines every day for green
lizards and wild boar and uh and long it
has and the uh the email suggested that
I should order a um a rainbow flag cover
for Bella's GPS device so that she could
uh show her prime pride month and uh I'm
afraid I was triggered and I wrote The
Grand Prix I rather Grandpa Lee wrote to
attractive in Austria and I said why
don't you just concentrate on tracking
dogs and uh and cease the virtual
signaling which I thought was a very a
fair enough point and I got a reply that
said uh we've taken thank you for your
email it was a very passive aggressive
reply thank you for your email uh We've
canceled your subscription to uh to
attractive so you can no longer track
your dog so um being the uh the the evil
journalist that I I maybe thought well
this is a good story I wrote it for The
Spectator got a huge reaction
um and you like the story too
um and you've now had an apology
then this morning
um the story continues fell as possible
is bedtime she's a little little that
first live television show
um I get an email from the Chief
Executive Officer of attractive Apollo
Bella is going to jump down and so
um you've seen all you're going to see
it fella
um I get a an email from the chief
executive back to apologizing you know
you know rather rather humbly and saying
that the person who canceled me had no
right to do so
um and that they'd indeed do respect uh
other points of view he said that
attractive continues to support uh Pride
which I guess is their right
um but all is well that ends well and
that fella can continue her
peregrinations in the vines without fear
of becoming lost should she be
distracted but it is an extraordinary
situation I think I think you're hit on
the head it's not about not wanting to
embrace the spirit of pride of course I
I do I'm sure you do it's why is there a
whole month of it why is it all so
completely over the top and why if you
raise any raised eyebrow even about your
dog having to embrace this then you get
canceled oh no that's it your dog can
die sorry it seems to me that uh that
this thing has has spun slightly out of
control and corporations in particular
and governments have embraced this as if
um
lgbtq x y z or whatever it now is is
some kind of ideology and I I don't
really understand why it should be so
sacred
um and I don't even actually accept that
lgbtq
Etc is really a community I I noticed in
the King's Birthday honors list which
was published a few days ago and in
which Mrs Miller my wife featured
um there was an award that was an award
given for services till the to the
lgbtq community I mean what really I
mean it's not really a community the
elves don't seem to get on particularly
well with the G's and the t's don't seem
to get on particularly well with any of
them that's true
um and and it's not certainly you know I
have gay friends and have had for years
I've had gay colleagues I have absolute
respect for gay people they can do
whatever they want but this kind of in
your face ideological Push by
corporations and governments to identify
with this strikes me as excessive and
not really
um proportionate given that there are
many many deserving I mean I gave my day
okay but again right month um I said I I
totally agree I think it is over the top
now and I don't like being forced to do
anything and I think what happened here
was you were basically told if you
didn't you know if you didn't go along
with this your dog would then be put in
danger have its tracking turned off I'll
read out a statement from Michael uh who
knows he's the CEO attractive he's
allowed to apologize one of our support
agents felt personally targeted reacted
in a manner he shouldn't have shouldn't
have happened we have internally taken
appropriate measures I want to emphasize
that we do not share your view but we do
accept different opinions I'm not even
sure he really knows what your view is
I've reinstated your service and added
three months of free service but an
interesting little twist there whether
he doesn't agree with your view it
presumably thinks you're homophobic
because if you don't agree with
everything that is laid down as law on
this stuff uh by the mob then you become
transphobic homophobic whatever it is
I'm none of those things I suspect
you're not either but continue to raise
eyebrows Jonathan because thanks to your
going public Bella has been uncanceled
has been uncanceled that's correct and
he's a very happy dog and it's past her
bedtime and probably past mine I won't
keep you any longer Jonathan I'm
delighted to see what a pleasure to see
you again last week and uh we'll talk
again it's great to see you thanks for
coming
take care all right thanks extraordinary
extraordinary State of Affairs